our series a more perfect union aims to
show what unites us as Americans is far
stronger than what divides us this
morning we introduced you to an
organization that gives students who
have a story to tell the opportunity to
share it young storytellers is a
nationwide mentoring program that
encourages kids to tap into their
creativity by connecting them with
experts in the entertainment industry
Jamie yuccas shows us how these pairings
help bring a child's imagination to life
in the shadows of the Hollywood sign
some of Tinseltown's brightest young
talent is hard at work fifth graders at
this Los Angeles school are crafting
their first screenplay I'm writing about
a dragon of the practical then I'm a
hunter
it's about a vampire named Molly and she
doesn't like blood Jeannie konigsberg a
paramount TV executive is one of the
mentors helping to turn that passion
into prose it's exciting to see the
stories turning in little kids heads and
get it out on paper it's really like the
best part of my week for nine weeks she
and other volunteers like TV development
executive Brad Saunders give the budding
screenwriters a crash course in how to
bring a script to the stage my job is to
just write down what he says maybe like
give him a little guidance but it's
amazing how it kind of always wraps up
in a really great package real actors
help complete that package but must
first audition
[Applause]
that's not people this handsome
Frenchman waiting Chrissie fit is no
stranger to Hollywood but the roles
actors land in this School Auditorium
[Applause]
have special meaning so is this as
exciting as getting a real Hollywood
part the nonprofit program runs in more
than 60 public schools in Los Angeles
New York City and Austin Texas reaching
about 2400 students every year dozens of
companies including CBS sponsor teams of
mentors we're not necessarily trying to
calculate the next great generation of
screenwriters if that happens fantastic
but really we want them to come out of
this being able to stand up in front of
a roomful of people
and articulate themselves in a confident
manner are you excited to see this now
come to life wife
[Music]
but this is on the day of the big show
the students get the star treatment
complete with a red carpet and front-row
seats to see their play come to life for
the first time does it make you want to
write more later
yes like more fiction than nonfiction
with twisted endings and surprises I see
you smiling why does that make you happy
I just I love that she wants twist
ending not something we stress in the
program it is really post go wherever
you want and go out of the bounds how
awesome is that
yeah really awesome yeah sometimes the
true Hollywood ending is discovering you
have the power to create your own for
CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Hollywood what a great
experience for everybody involved yeah
everybody kids are such truth-tellers
too I love the role reversal I did as
well right
also when you write something you to see
it then animated by human beings by
adults to tell adults what to do what a
great so rewarding yeah a vampire that
doesn't like blood I like that he's
owning something here it seems